herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren
was haben islamische fundamentalisten
rechtspopulisten und feministin
gemeinsam sie alle sorgen sich um ihre
identität und suchen nach anerkennung
das zumindest behauptet mein heutiger
gast der einflussreiche us amerikanische
politologe francis fukuyama herzlich
willkommen reykjavik knapp 30 jahren
wurden sie auf einen schlag kann man
sagen weltbekannt damals zeichnete sich
das ende der sowjetunion ab der fall der
berliner mauer
wir sehen hier bilder davon und sie
sagten sie sterben die these auf dieses
ereignis bedeute das ende der geschichte
was haben sie damals damit gemeint der
titel war eine anspielung auf das
marxistische verständnis von geschichte
als ein entwicklungsprozess bei dem
unterschiedliche stadien durchschritten
werden bis der endpunkt der entwicklung
erreicht ist das ende der geschichte
die marxisten argumentieren dass der
kommunismus die letzte entwicklungsstufe
der menschheit darstellt im
ursprünglichen artikel von 1989
formulierte ich den titel als frage ich
argumentierte dass der kommunismus nicht
in reichweite schien sondern dass die
bürgerliche demokratie wie mag sie
nannte wohl die letzte zivilisatorischen
stufe darstellt wir waren damals mitten
in einer großen welle der
demokratisierung ausgelöst vom fall der
mauer die these besagte nicht dass
demokratie universell sei sondern dass
es einen trend zur demokratie
gibt und dass diese wohl die höchste
entwicklungsstufe bleiben würde
zu diesem zeitpunkt zeichnete sich ab
dass es eigentlich zu den liberalen
demokratien hinten wieder zu
marktwirtschaftlichen system also der
kapitalismus aus zum kommunismus
jetzt haben sie dieses buch here oder
den aufsatz vor wie ich gesagt habe ich
vor knapp 30 jahren geschrieben hat sich
diese these bewahrheitet heute gemäss
dem politologen samuel huntington
erfolgte zwischen 1970 und ca 2010 die
dritte welle der demokratie als die zahl
der demokratie in der welt von 35 auf
ungefähr 115 anstieg mit einer starken
zunahme in asien afrika und
lateinamerika
diese periode ist mittlerweile klar zu
ende und wir erleben eine umkehr
die demokratie ist zusehends bedroht
durch autoritäre länder wie russland
oder china und durch den anstieg des
populismus
die große frage in zukunft wird sein ob
der trend in richtung demokratie
endgültig gebrochen ist oder ob wenig
wie beim verlauf des aktienmarkts der
positive trend lediglich einen
rückschlag erfährt
und was sind die ursachen dieser krise
der demokratie die wir erleben die krise
resultiert teilweise aus der weltweiten
globalisierung nicht nur die demokratie
sondern auch eine reihe von liberalen
ideen haben sich weltweit verankert
durch offene grenzen für handel
investitionen und personen kam es in den
letzten 40 jahren zu einer explosiven
zunahme der verflechtung der reichtum in
vielen ländern stieg aber nicht alle
konnten darf
profitieren in vielen entwickelten
reichen ländern hat die arbeiterklasse
zusehen müssen wie ihre jobs nach asien
und in andere weltgegenden verlagert
worden sind wiemer mehr fremde ins land
geströmt sind was vor allem in der
migrations krise 2015 in europa sichtbar
wurde
all das löst eine populistische
gegenbewegung zum weltweiten
globalisierungs trend regel für diese
bewerten und interessant ist auch sie
sagen
die ursachen für diese welle des
rechtspopulismus das sind nicht primär
wirtschaftliche ursachen abstiegsängste
der mittelschicht sondern kulturelle
ursachen angst vor identitätsverlust
express und die grafik war bereits die
canucks das ist richtig hinter den
wirtschaftlichen gründen steckt oft eine
kulturelle dimension wenn ich meine
stelle verliere oder weniger verdiene
als mein vater sehe ich dies als
statusverlust an
schuld daran sind dann schnell einmal
die fremden der internationale
wettbewerb oder die migranten die ins
land strömen arbeitsplätze wegnähmen und
den sozialstaat untergraben
in den nullerjahren kam es zu grossen
subprime hypothekenkrise in den usa 2008
um zur euro krise unter diesem versagen
der großen banken und der eliten litten
vor allem die einfachen menschen
normalerweise ist
ist der nährboden für linkspopulistische
kräfte tatsächlich ist in den usa aber
die tea party aufgekommen und in europa
profitierten die migrations feindlichen
parteien mit ihrem straff
nationalistischen und gegen die eu
gerichteten kurs dies zeugt davon dass
die kulturelle dimension und fragen der
identität wichtiger sind als die
wirtschaftliche ungleichheit die wir
heute beobachten
und da finde ich sie sehr originell sie
haben schon in ihrem alten buch aber
auch im neuen buch über identity bringen
sie einen begriff nämlich ein begriff
den schon platon verwendet hat aus dem
altgriechischen nämlich thymus ein
streben nach anerkennung vielleicht auch
ein sehnsucht danach stolz auf etwas
sein zu können auf eine identität die
man hat warum ist dieser teams so
wichtig das altgriechische wort thymus
bezeichnet das universelle streben nach
anerkennung
die menschen wollen mehr als nur
materialistische dinge essen trinken und
geld für den respekt unsere mitmenschen
sind wir sogar bereit auf
wirtschaftliche vorteile zu verzichten
bewegt auch die politik ich bin mit dem
großen philosophen hegel einig den
diesem geld und streben eine starke
antriebskraft für den fortschritt der
geschichte erkannte so erhoben sich zur
zeit der französischen revolution die
sklaven weil sie ihre menschenwürde
nicht respektiert sahen dieses schreiben
einzelner gruppen nach würde und
anerkennung ist eine der wichtigsten
antriebsfedern in der moderne
ich sah ich eine anthropologische these
sagen sie also dann das zeichen den
menschen also ein grundbedürfnis
und die politik muss das irgendwie auch
befriedigen gibt es da in die empirische
psychologische studien dazu dass dieses
bedürfnis so wichtig ist
tatsächlich zeigen viele studien dass es
dafür eine biologische grundlage gibt
so schüttet das gehirn den
neurotransmitter serotonin aus wenn man
anerkennung erfährt sogar unter
menschenaffen etwa den schimpansen hat
das alphamännchen erhöhte serotonin
werte es ist also in unserer biologie
begründet es gab in der moderne eine
spezifische manifestation dieses
strebens nach würde
wir haben letztes jahr das 500 jahr
jubiläum der reformation gefeiert
die reformation und insbesondere
unterschriften stehen für dieses moderne
verständnis der anerkennung in dem der
christliche glaube nicht mehr durch
sichtbare äußere handlungen und rituale
sondern durch die innere haltung gezeigt
wird in diesem modernen verständnis
gewählt die würde untrennbar zu menschen
sie stellt einen inneren wert dar der
mit der reformation seinen platz einnahm
luthe stellte den glauben auf eine neue
grundlage und untergrub damit die
grundfeste der mittelalterlichen kirche
es wirklich interessant und dieses
dieses bedürfnis nach anerkennung des
eigenen werks das sagen sie so zentral
dass es ganz unterschiedliche phänomene
der heutigen zeit erklären kann gegen
rechtspopulismus also phänomene wie
trump drexhage aber noch andere wählen
sie sagen auch die in die miete bewegung
also feministische bewegung oder etwa
die black wings med
schwarze bürgerrechtsbewegung und sogar
religiösen fundamentalismus als zum
beispiel den islamischen staat
würden sie sagen letztlich geht es darum
das selbe grund bittet ist das dahinter
steckt
es ist erst einmal wichtig darauf
hinzuweisen dass die bewegungen die sie
erwähnt haben moralisch nicht
gleichzusetzen sind
auch wenn sie vielleicht durch einen
ähnlichen psychologischen drang nach
anerkennung und würde angetrieben werden
in der mito bewegung während sich frauen
in den usa oder europa gegen sexuelle
gewalt und belästigung und auch die
bleibt live smarter bewegung widersetzt
sich der ungerechtigkeit
nun könnte man anführen dass wladimir
putin sich gegen wir ab würdigung
russlands nach dem zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion wird
sein unmut trifft sich dann aber im
versuch aus die nachbarstaaten ukraine
georgien und die baltischen staaten
zugänge moralisch lässt sich das
natürlich nicht mit einem afroamerikaner
vergleichen der sich gegen polizeigewalt
zur wehr setzt psychologischer
beteiligen diese menschen das gefühl in
ihrem inneren wert nicht respektiert zu
werden und dieser respekt wird dann
politisch eingefordert also sie
unterscheiden psychologische ursachen
und die sind ziemlich ähnlich bei diesen
bewegung und dann die moralischen gründe
dafür
die sind dann natürlich andere beide
bewegungen beim feminismus und weiter
schwarzen bürgerrechtsbewegung finde ich
interessant aber warum definieren wir
uns heute so sehr über kunden
identitäten wir könnten ja sagen es ist
ein zeitalter das liberale das
individualismus
aber es irgendwie möchten wir heute alle
kennen und finden aus teil einer gruppe
warum ist dieses kundengruppen denken
heute so stark ausgeprägt
[Musik]
dafür gibt es eine ganze anzahl von
gründen die liberale gesellschaft fuß
die auf der prämisse dass wir alle
individuen sind identitätspolitik hat
zuerst in der forderung nach
persönlicher befreiung ausdruck gefunden
unter der hippie bewegung in san
francisco der 60er jahre herrschte das
gefühl von der gesellschaft daran
gehindert zu werden sich voll zu
entfalten und frei zu werden
wenn menschen aber tief in sich gehen
finden sie oft keine einzigartige person
sondern stoßen auf eine lehre und den
bund sich mit anderen zu verbinden
das wahre ich entsteht aus der
verbindung mit anderen menschen
ich denke das steckt hinter dem ansatz
seine identität über eine gruppe zu
definieren
ein beispiel dafür ist das erstarken des
katalanischen nationalismus nach dem
ende des franco muss waren viele
katalanen versöhnt damit in einem
demokratischen spanien zu leben anderen
reichte das nicht sie brauchten zur
erfüllung ihrer identität eine
gemeinsame sprache und eine geschichte
die sich von der spaniens unterscheidet
das steckt hinter der forderung nach
anerkennung kataloniens es ist schon
interessant
wir leben in einer zeit wo wir ungeheure
freiheiten haben und trotzdem wenn man
sich anschaut was wichtig ist ist es das
was um verfügbar ist was wir nicht
ändern können die hautfarbe zb das
geschlecht die eigene geschichte
warum ist das so es ist in der tat
ziemlich ironisch
ursache dafür sind vorgefasste meinungen
rassen vorurteile oder diskriminierung
nach geschlecht das also ein schwarzer
ein muslim ein erfahrung von der
gesellschaft als angehöriger einer
gruppe und nicht als individuum gesehen
wird
gegen diese form der stereotypisierung
während sich angehörige dieser gruppen
gleichzeitig aber wollen sie das ansehen
der gruppe heben und betonen dabei ihre
eigenständige identität auf grund der
sie sich abheben von allen anderen in
der gesellschaft mit ihrer gelebten
erfahrung afroamerikaner erfahren in
ihrem leben diskriminierung durch die
weiße mehrheit und frauen machen ganz
andere erfahrungen als männer
innerhalb der feministischen bewegung
setzt ein teil bei der gleichbehandlung
in die zuger flohen aufstiegs und
arbeitsmöglichkeiten an wogegen ein
anderer teil meint frauen seien anders
als männer denen aufgrund ihrer
aggressivität ihrer team unfähigkeit die
tugenden der frauen fielen diese frauen
wollen nicht auf eine stufe mit männern
gebracht werden sondern in ihrer
eigenständigkeit wahrgenommen werden
das ist teil der dynamik die zu dieser
rückkehr der biologie führte wo man
glaubt das verhalten denken und
politische agieren sei durch die natur
vorgegeben und was dazukommt ist noch
diese dieser wert des authentischen dass
man echt ist also es geht so weit dass
donald trump zum präsident wird weil er
politisch korrektes verletzt und weil ab
welches sich über behinderte und frauen
lustig machten zweiter hauptsache es ist
irgendwie authentisch warum ist dieses
echte warum hat er so einen großen
stellenwert heute dieses im westlichen
denkens bis das thema der echtheit schon
lange behandelt so auch durch jean
jacques rousseau den großen philosophen
aus genf in meinem buch gehe ich auf
seine these ein dass die gesellschaft
mit ihren starren regeln falsch und
verlogen ist und die menschen von ihrem
glücklichen naturzustand entfremdet sind
in der vergesellschaftung verlieren sie
das bewusstsein für ihren wahren inneren
kern ich war mit dieser betonung der
authentizität nicht allein
kant meinte es sei unsere moralische
handlungsfähigkeit die uns zu wertvollen
menschen macht im neunzehnten
jahrhundert entwickelt sich der gedanke
des wahren inneren selbst zum glauben an
die innere kreativität und den inneren
werkt einer person dieses gedankengut
ist im westen also seit langem
vorhandene jetzt kann man sagen das ist
ja nicht etwas gutes wenn man sich für
benachteiligte gruppen einsetzt und
sozusagen den einzelnen zu seinem recht
kommen lässt selbst entfalten und so
weiter jetzt sagen sie aber die linken
parteien die sich das auf die fahne
geschrieben haben sind zu weit gegangen
mit dieser identitätspolitik wie das
wird das genannt wird das heißt dass man
eben für minderheiten sich einsetzt wie
ist es dazu gekommen dass zu dieser
identitätspolitik der linken und jetzt
88 der rechten die linke hat
ungleichheit früher eine rein
wirtschaftliche kategorie neu definiert
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert setzten sich
die kommunisten und sozialisten für die
arbeit der klasse 1 die zu der zeit aus
weißen männern als angehörige der
dominanten
ethnische gesellschaftsgruppe bestand
mehr und mehr brachte man den
wirtschaftlichen abstieg in zusammenhang
mit der diskriminierung spezifischer
minderheiten und diese parteien verloren
den kontakt zu den weißen
wählerschichten die früher ihren kern
ausmacht
ein neuer ideologische
multikulturalismus deutete
gleichberechtigung nicht als gleichheit
der einzelnen sondern der gruppen
folglich galt ist das selbstwertgefühl
der gruppe zu steigern
selbst wenn sich diese gruppe
diskriminierend gegenüber den einzelnen
angehörigen der gruppe verhielt was dich
zu einer liberalen gesellschaft
allmählich wuchs unter den weißen
wählern als angehörige der ethnischen
mehrheit das gefühl diese parteien
vertreten nicht mehr ihre interessen und
sie wanderten in großer zahl zu diesen
rechtsaußen parteien wie die identität
dieser wähler klasse besser zu schützen
versprachen
so verloren in den usa die demokraten in
den letzten 30 jahren viele wähler an
die republikaner und auch in europa
geschah ähnliches
die kommunistische partei in frankreich
war früher fest verankert im proletariat
und heute wählen viele dieser leute den
front national
also sie sagen nicht dass es irgendwie
schlecht ist dass man sich für diese
minderheiten eingesetzt hat sondern man
hat eigentlich die weiße arbeiterschicht
vergessen und die armut und die
ungleichheit aus dem blick verloren die
die linken parteien man hätte einfach
einfach beides machen ist sozusagen das
war schon richtig sich für diese
minderheiten einzusetzen aber das andere
hätte man genauso gut machen müssen
würden sie sagen
das ist richtig
zusätzlich aber wurde es politisch
korrekt im interesse grundlegende
soziale gerechtigkeit die rechte von
minderheiten von frauen schwulen und
lesben zu betonen oft zu lasten der
gruppe die frühe gesellschaftlich
tonangebend war
so geriet die weiße arbeiterschicht aus
dem fokus von hollywood und den beiden
großen parteien und der elite kultur
selbst als sie durch outsourcing und
internationalen wettbewerb arbeitslos
wurde
so stieg die wut über ihre ausgrenzung
durch das system diese wut führte zur
wahl von donald trump aber sie geht noch
einen schritt weiter und sie sagen nach
unsere gesellschaften wie man das in den
usa sie zersplittern in diese gruppen
und was ist daran eigentlich so
gefährlich aus ihrer sicht im nahen
osten oder dem balkan besteht politik
nur aus identitätspolitik syrien irak
libyen afghanistan somalia
das sind alles länder die zu vielen weil
sie keine umfassende nationale identität
haben
sie bestehen aus gruppen die sich über
ihre ethnizität religion sekten oder in
bestimmten fällen auch
stammeszugehörigkeit definieren
es fehlt die loyalität zu einer
übergeordneten politischen einheit die
ein zusammenleben als ganzes ermöglichen
würde
in europäischen ländern und den usa gab
es immer schon minderheiten
man hat sich aber um ihre integration in
die gesellschaft bemüht in der hoffnung
parallelgesellschaften zu verhindern
in denen diese identitäts gruppen auf
immer eine minderheit blieben mit ihrer
eigenen sprache und ihrem eigenen
brauchtum mann war damit in den usa
sicherlich erfolgreicher als in europa
hier besteht die gefahr dass gruppen von
migranten nicht als vollwertige
mitglieder in die gesellschaft
integriert werden und sich in
parallelgesellschaften verabschieden das
geschieht sogar oft noch in der dritten
generation nicht ich möchte mit ihnen
gleich noch über ihren ihren
lösungsvorschlag sprechen nämlich über
diese nationalen identitäten die sie die
sie fordern zunächst aber eine
persönliche frage wie steht es denn um
ihre identität
was hat ihre identität am stärksten
geprägt wenn sie auf ihre biografie
zurückblicken
mein großvater väterlicherseits kam 1905
also vor über 110 jahren aus japan nach
amerika um der einberufungen die
japanische armee während des russisch
japanischen krieg zu entgehen
er hat ein eisenwarengeschäft gegründet
mein vater wuchs in los angeles auf er
war stark amerikanisiert und sprach nur
noch wenig japanisch ich selbst spreche
überhaupt kein japanisch mehr
ich wuchs in new york auf in den 50er
und 60er jahren gab es dort keine
eigentliche asiatische gesellschaft ich
habe mich immer als amerikaner gesehen
nicht als japan oder asien amerikaner
das entsprach auch der erfahrung meines
vaters wir wurden nicht anders behandelt
weil wir einen anderen rassen
hintergrund hatten
sicher wurde mir diese frage gestellt
aber meine antwort darauf war ich komme
aus chicago eine durchaus übliche
antwort in amerika wo man nicht über
seine identität definiert wird sondern
durch den glauben es an bestimmte
amerikanische werte oder anhand der
sprache akzentfrei englisch spricht und
sich wie ein amerikaner verhält wird
auch als solche akzeptiert
das stört mich auch an der heutigen
situation in den usa vermehrt verbreiten
rückständige weiße nationalisten das
gedankengut das nur weisse amerikaner
echte amerikaner sind ein solches
ethnisches verständnis wer ein echter
rückschritt
sie sind heute ein dezidierter gegner
der politik von trump sie haben aber
kann man sagen politisch die seiten
gewechselt ungefähr um 2003 vor dem
irak-krieg davor waren sie im umfeld der
neokonservativen haben mit paul
wolfowitz zum beispiel auch 1998 zum
sturz von saddam hussein aufgerufen und
dann vor dem irakkrieg an die wände und
sie haben sich distanziert und sind
heute beiden demokraten könnte man sagen
waren davor auch lang politischer
berater der sphinx von von reagan und
bush senior
was hat den anschlag gegeben für diesen
politischen gesinnungswechsel das war
eine reaktion auf das was in der
realität geschah auf den irak krieg und
die finanzkrise
die beiden wichtigsten ereignisse in den
nullerjahren dass ein krieg im irak ein
gewaltiger außenpolitischen fehler wäre
war mir klar
er erwies sich als noch größer als von
mir befürchtet der krieg fußte auf der
konservativen idee dass die usa mit
ihrer militärmacht die politik einer
kulturell andersartigen regierung neu
gestalten könnte und die finanzkrise
resultierte aus einem exzessiven
liberalismus
gemäss dem unregulierte märkte sich
selbst kontrollieren würden beide
ansichten erwiesen sich als zutiefst
fehlerbehaftet aufgrund dieser überaus
liberalen politik entstanden unter
ronald reagan und margaret thatcher in
den usa und großbritannien immer größere
ungleichheiten im zug der sogenannten
neoliberalen revolution wurde der
wohlfahrtsstaat über geringere
zuwendungen und die regulierung abgebaut
teilweise war dies gerechtfertigt
angesichts des massiven anstiegs der
ungleichheit in den letzten 30 40 jahren
aber muss man konstatieren dass man viel
zu weit gegangen ist
die welt hat sich also verändert und so
auch meine politische haltung aber sie
würden nicht sagen dass ihre position
damals in den 80er und 90er jahren
falsch war sondern damals war es richtig
ja ich glaube es gab gute gründe für
genießer und treasuries am ende der 1970
er jahre konnten sich viele entwickelte
länder ihre sozialhilfe systeme nicht
mehr leisten
dies führte zur hyperinflation und
stagnierendem wachstum
es gab in vielen bereichen zu viel
regulierung ich glaube dass es damals
richtig war bestimmte verkrustungen in
der politik aufzubrechen
aber in der politik kommt es oft zu
pendelbewegungen während der
weltwirtschaftskrise der 30er jahre
die politik zu liberal dann begann und
alles zu regulieren was zur stagnation
der 70er jahre führte darauf folgte eine
deregulierung und jedes wahl die man
etwas zu weit was wieder zu einem
wirtschaftspolitischen umdenken führte
jetzt heute in ihrem neuen buch identity
schlagen sie etwas vor und zwar hat dass
man diese zersplitterung der der
gesellschaft aufhalten sollte und wieder
in größeren kollektiven denkt man sich
identifizieren sollte nämlich sie
fordert weiter sich nationale identität
eine art von nationalstolz können sie
diese idee ein bisschen erläutern und
behielt 2010 bei der nazis preisvergabe
in genf eine ansprache zu dieser frage
im europäischen kontext der sich wegen
der eu vom kontexte usa unterscheidet
die gründer der europäischen union sahen
in nationalen identitäten ein feindbild
aggressiver internationalismus hatte zu
zwei weltkriegen geführt und die eu war
darauf ausgelegt die nationalen
identitäten der mitgliedstaaten
frankreich großbritannien deutschland
durch eine art pan europäische identität
zu ersetzen
in anlehnung an die post nationale
vision eines jürgen habermas dem
deutschen philosophen diese durchaus
noble idee war in bestimmten bereichen
auch spektakulär erfolgreich zum
beispiel bei der reduktion der
wahrscheinlichkeit eines kriegs zwischen
deutschland und frankreich nicht
erfolgreich aber war man bei der
schaffung einer echten europäischen
identität welche die identitäten der
einzelnen mitgliedsländer tatsächlich
ersetzen konnte
die euro krise brachte dieses versagen
zum vorschein
nach der krise waren sich deutsche und
griechen sehr viel
darüber was sie trennte als darüber was
sie verband
während die deutschen durchaus bereit
waren schwächeren mitbürgern mit den
mitteln des sozialstaats unter die arme
zu greifen
sahen sie die griechen nicht als teil
einer großfamilie an für die man bereit
ist zu sorgen
so wartet europa immer noch auf eine
integrierende identität ein starkes
gefühl der zugehörigkeit zu europa wäre
schön aber im moment halten wir an
unseren nationalen identitäten fest das
ist auch wichtig denn man muss die
menschen integrieren
erfolgreiche demokratien müssen auf die
legitimität gemeinsame institutionen
vertrauen können
aber ist das reicht das denn so ein
bekenntnis zu diesen grundwerten zu der
verfassung des eigenen landes oder also
es wäre so etwas wie der jürgen habermas
verfassungspatriotismus genannt hat
reicht das oder braucht es mehr braucht
dass wir deswegen gemeinsam lebensstil
eine leitkultur wird zum beispiel die in
deutschland heftig das hängt davon ab
was mit leitkultur gemeint ist der
begriff stammt von bassam tibi einem
syrischen professor der in deutschland
ausgebildet wurde
er verstand darunter eine kultur die
nicht von der religion oder tief
verankerten kulturellen gewohnheiten
geprägt ist sondern von einem bekenntnis
zu den werten der aufklärung leitkultur
ist mehr als ein bekenntnis zur
verfassung
dazu gehört auch der glaube an die
westlichen werte die modernen
demokratien zu grunde liegen
ein bloßes bekenntnis zu politischen
grundsätzen reicht wohl nicht aus um ein
land zusammenzuhalten
es braucht auch rituale feiertage
gemeinsames essen und da wird es oft
schwierig weil nicht alle diese
gewohnheiten teilen
herbert können sie gleich ein beispiel
geben wohl zum beispiel eine eine
muslimische person bestimmt die
tradition aufgeben muss sich an dieses
an dieser leitkuh so anzupassen dass
ihre sich ganz konkret was das bedeutet
dass hier ist die antwort relativ klar
in vielen muslimischen familien soll die
tochter jemanden heiraten der der
familie genehm ist
so wird die tochter für eine arrangierte
hochzeit zurück ins ursprungsland nach
marokko oder pakistan geschickt
es gibt auch andere prägende ansichten
von gewissen gemeinschaften wie
antisemitismus oder eine feindselige
haltung schwulen und lesben gegenüber
das beispiel der tochter ist als
kulturelle praxis weit verbreitet in der
muslimischen welt aber nicht vereinbar
mit liberalen grundprinzipien in einer
liberalen demokratie glauben wir dass
alle menschen und dazu gehören auch alle
frauen mündig sind das heißt sie
genießen entscheidungsfreiheit bei den
wichtigsten lebens entscheiden
insbesondere wen sie heiraten in einer
liberalen demokratie darf eine familie
nicht das recht haben die tochter in
eine ehe zu zwingen
das ist ein beispiel wo eine kulturelle
praxis die linie überschreitet und ein
grundprinzip des liberalen
individualismus untergräbt der das
fundament unserer demokratie darstellt
im rahmen dieser grund und menschenrecht
ist auch kulturelle vielfalt möglich
aber ich habe den eindruck sie haben
etwas gegen diesen multikulturalismus
was ist denn daran gefährlich es hängt
davon ab wie sie multikulturalismus
definieren
man kann die definition auf die
empirische feststellung beschränken dass
in einer gesellschaft unterschiedliche
kulturen existieren die ideologische
version des multikulturalismus besagt
dass alle kulturen gleich wertvoll sind
und gleichermaßen respektiert sein
sollen
das hat auch zu einer extremen
anti-westlichen ausprägung des
multikulturalismus geführt in der
sklaverei kolonialismus und rassismus
als essenz der westlichen kultur
angesehen werden
die deshalb zu verurteilen ist für mich
ist das eine lächerliche behauptung
natürlich stimmt es historisch in
gewisser weise sie ist aber auch
grundfalsch eine andere problematische
version besagt dass alle kulturen gleich
behandelt werden müssen
hier liegt ein missverständnis über die
grundprinzipien einer modernen
demokratie vor pluralismus meint nicht
einen pluralismus der kulturen sondern
einen pluralismus der individuen die
rechte des einzelnen übersteigen die
rechte der kulturellen gemeinschaft in
der sie leben in einer wahren liberalen
demokratie müssen wir deshalb nicht so
sehr die rechte der kulturellen gruppen
sondern die rechte des individuums
schützen
natürlich machen wir kulturellen gruppen
zugeständnisse weil menschen so leben
wollen
aber das beispiel der zwangsehe zeigt
dass es grenzen gibt für die toleranz
bestimmte praktiken also keine zu
starken zugeständnissen keine
sonderrechte für andere kulturen die
irgendwie das grundrecht
überschreiten dass das fordern sie sie
sprechen aber immer von assimilation an
diese bestehende bekenntnis identität an
diese nationale identität nicht von
integration und integration scheint
etwas zu sein ein wechselseitiger
prozess wo sich ein land seine kultur
verändern kann durch zuwanderungen aber
sie bei ihnen ging das so statisch was
man haben diese identität des landes und
alle müssten sich daran anpassen die in
diesem land leben
ich erachte die beiden begriffe
assimilation und integration als sehr
ähnlich natürlich muss auch die
dominante kultur anerkennen dass man
dinge anders machen kann dass es eine
vielfalt von lebensformen unter bürgern
gibt die man tolerieren und akzeptieren
muss umgekehrt haben moderne demokratien
ihre eigene kultur in der entgegenkommen
toleranz die freiheit des einzelnen
unter grundsatz der gleichheit groß
geschrieben werden
diese kulturellen werte darf man nicht
verletzen
man darf menschen die mit grundsätzlich
anderen werten ins land gekommen sind
nicht zu weit entgegenkommen dass man
undemokratische welt akzeptiert wir
haben über dieses gemeinschaftsgefühl
gesprochen und wenn man sich fragt
jemand aus herstellen kann
diese gemeinsame kultur diese identität
dann ist die frage ob es reicht wenn man
einfach eine verfassung hat oder
bestimmte grundrechte oberst oder ober
sagt tradition bestimmte rituale
brauchen und meine kollegin barbara
bleisch hat vor einiger zeit mit den us
politologen mark lilla gesprochen der
diese ganze debatte über die
identitätspolitik und die kritik an der
linken angestoßen hat und er meint das
braucht ein bisschen mehr um ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl herzustellen wir
hören uns das ganz kurz sein
wir haben keine präzise ja
zum beispiel den militärdienst als eine
form von wie man eine nationale
identität stiften
sie kennen das noch in der schweiz in
den usa existiert das nicht mehr
aber mark lilla hat recht es braucht
diese gemeinsamen symbole
letzte woche hat man in den usa
thanksgiving gefeiert den wohl
wichtigsten nationalen feiertag in den
usa
man hört oft dass die pilgerväter das
erntedankfest begründet hätten als
nationalen feiertag festgesetzt hat es
aber abraham lincoln in der absicht ein
land wieder zusammenzuführen das einen
schrecklichen bürgerkrieg hinter sich
hatte indem 600.000 amerikaner auf
schlachtfeldern umkamen
der versuch war erfolgreich denn alle
amerikaner teilen heute dieses symbol
wurde ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
als nationale sportart geschaffen um die
südstaaten nach dem bürgerkrieg wieder
in die union aufzunehmen
man hatte das gefühl es brauche ein
gemeinsames freizeitvergnügen mit dem
sich alle amerikaner identifizieren
können und das so zum einigen ein symbol
würde in meinem buch erwähne ich den
film entdeckt es über südafrika der film
thematisiert nelson mandelas versuch
als erster schwarzer präsident
südafrikas unter der schwarzen
bevölkerung begeisterung für das
südafrikanische rugby-team der
springboks zu kreieren
im südafrika der apartheid spielten die
schwarzen fußball und die weißen rugby
das rugby team war denn auch fast
ausschließlich weiß mandela sah die
notwendigkeit für nationale symbole und
wollte aus rugby einen nationalsport
machen anstatt eines sports verweise
afrikaner
das sind beispiele dafür wie visionäre
für ihre gemeinsame symbole und eine
gemeinsame kultur schaffen
man hört immer wieder dass fußball auch
diese integrative kraft hat und aber es
kann problematisch sein man sieht dann
bei den nationalen spielen singen einige
die höhe und andere schweigen als
schweizer und das löst diskussionen
natürlich auch aus sie plädieren
eigentlich in ihrem buch das hat mich
überrascht
gegen doppelbürger schafften was man
sollte nicht länger von zwei ländern
sein
was ist denn daran die erste tour
citizenship
die doppelte staatsbürgerschaft maxi
praktisch sein für bestimmte weltläufige
personen die auf den wohnsitz wechseln
deren ehepartner aus einem anderen land
kommt oder die eingewandert sind
es ist nicht so sehr ein problem wenn
beide länder demokratisch sind und
bestimmte werte teilen
er schafft aber problemlos
unterschiedliche grundsätze und
loyalitäten gegenüber einem
bestehen zb bei der türkei oder russland
im buch erwähne ich die türkei die unter
präsident erdogan immer autoritärer wird
er hat türkischstämmige deutsche
aufgefordert politiker zu wählen die
nicht im interesse deutschlands sondern
im interesse der türkei agieren
das ist nur ein beispiel einer geteilten
realität
als deutscher staatsbürger sollte man
sich an das halten was wird deutschland
am besten ist
aus diesem grund gefällt mir die idee
der doppelten staatsbürgerschaft nicht
besteht die möglichkeit eines kriegs
wird das ganze noch viel problematischer
weil man dann wirklich entscheiden muss
auf welcher seite man steht
aber selbst ohne eine kriegsgefahr ist
es ein problem wenn länder
unterschiedliche werte haben wir haben
jetzt wieder über diese zuwanderung
gesprochen und tatsächlich scheint die
migration eine ganz zentrale ursache zu
sein für diese identitätsverlust ängste
die die kulturellen die wir angesprochen
haben und wir alle kennen die die bilder
von den flüchtlingsströmen bei uns war
das ende 2015 die kriegsflüchtlinge aus
syrien
hier sehen wir die
die flüchtlinge auf der balkanroute und
im mittelmeer und der zeit die bilder
von der mexikanischen grenze zu den usa
sie fordern bessere grenzkontrollen und
strengere einbürgerungsverfahren was
heißt das ganz konkret das ist ein
schwieriges thema weil ich nicht mit
donald trump gleichgesetzt werden möchte
auch wenn er ähnliches sagt aber ich
glaube nicht dass man eine demokratie
haben kann ohne festzulegen wer der
souverän ist
dafür braucht es grenzkontrollen deshalb
ist illegale einwanderung problematisch
ich erachte immigration als notwendig
und es etwas gutes für die meisten
länder die migration führt zur
wirtschaftswachstum kulturelle
diversität ist gut für eine gesellschaft
aber wenn sie unbegrenzt verläuft und
wenn die zu strömende menge die
aufnahmefähigkeit und letztlich die
assimilation so der
integrationsfähigkeit übersteigt hat man
ein problem aber wenn es zu schnell geht
und zu viel sind dann darf man selbst
syrische kriegsflüchtlinge abhalten oder
was bedeutet dass die sache ist komplex
ja man kann nicht jeden aufnehmen und
das ist aus humanitärer sicht
bedauerlich aber mit blick auf die
weltweite demographie ist klar dass sehr
viele menschen heute und in kommenden
generationen in die reichen länder
auswandern wollen
es wird die entwickelten gesellschaften
in ihrem überleben bedrohen wenn es
nicht gelingt diesen prozess so zu
steuern dass man die menschen
assimilieren kann über eine andere seite
der migration in euro
spricht man selten die offenheit für
immigration hat dazu geführt dass große
landstriche in osteuropa entvölkert
worden sind die ukraine serbien rumänien
bulgarien haben in der letzten
generation 20 bis 30 prozent der
bevölkerung verloren
oft waren es die fähigsten und am besten
ausgebildeten ehrgeizigsten leute die
nach london- hamburg oder sonst wo hin
gezogen sind ein politisch komplett
durchlässiges migrations system ist also
weder für die herkunft noch die
einwanderungsländer wirklich gut aber es
schon überraschend dass sie in dieser
zeit wo man denkt die großen probleme
die die menschheit hat sind globale
probleme migration klimawandel der
digitalisierung auf eine bestimmte weise
und sie plädieren in dieser zeit wieder
zurück zum nationalstaat grenzen stärker
nach den us staaten zu denken war warum
es geht wie gesagt um ein demokratisches
grundprinzip eine demokratie gründet auf
der souveränität des volkes
man muss also wissen wer das volk ist
deshalb ist es unabdingbar grenzen zu
sichern
denn wenn sich der souverän nicht abhebt
von anderen nationalen gruppen lässt
sich eine demokratie nicht erhalten
das heißt nicht dass waren kein
mitgefühl für migranten oder flüchtlinge
hat es besteht auch durchaus eine
moralische pflicht so vielen menschen
wie möglich zu helfen
aber es gibt keine unbegrenzte
verantwortung man könnte sich ja auch
die eu aus eine demokratische
institutionen vorstellen endlich wie die
vereinigten staaten von amerika also
über staatliche organisation könnten ja
auch irgendwann auch demokratisch sein
vielleicht irgendwann eine welt stand
sicher das wäre eine vision das problem
in der eu ist aber dass es ohne
sicherung der außengrenzen keine
reisefreiheit innerhalb der schengen
zone geben kann man hat entweder das
eine oder das andere begrenzte
reisefreiheit innerhalb der zone und
offene außengrenzen oder sichere
außengrenzen und reisefreiheit innerhalb
der zone
die eu arbeitet ja auch daran die
außengrenzen besser abzusichern
italien und griechenland die
haupteinfallstor nach europa sind stark
unter druck
auf dauer wird das schwierig so ihr
blick auf die globalen probleme
interessieren
auch die globalen kräfteverhältnisse
auch im politischen also wenn man sich
jetzt den aufstieg chinas transit
unglaubliches wirtschaftswachstum in den
letzten jahren erzählen damit auch
politische macht verbunden
droht da ein neuer kalter krieg zwischen
china und den usa
wenn man nachts die
handelsstreitigkeiten die haltung china
gegenüber hat sich aufgrund des
verhaltens von china stark verändert die
geschäftswelt in europa und den usa hat
sich lange für enge
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zwischen dem
westen und china eingesetzt
das hat sich in den letzten paar jahren
komplett verändert weil die chinesen
sich etwa beim geistigen eigentum und
gleichwertigen marktzugang nicht an die
regeln des internationalen handels
systems gehalten haben
jean ping hat angekündigt künftig die
eigenen high tech firmen zu
subventionieren
das nicht vereinbar ist mit dem globalen
handels rechtsrahmen
entsprechend sind größere spannungen
unvermeidbar auch die chinesische
außenpolitik ist seit 2008 viel
aggressiver geworden mit der
militarisierung dieser inseln im
südchinesischen meer im bestreben das
chinesische staatsgebiet gegen den
widerstand der nachbarländer zu
erweitern
ich meine das nicht anklagen zu
verhalten sich nunmal länder wenn sie
erstarken ihre ziele werden ehrgeizige
und sie werden aggressiver
das heißt aber nicht dass man sich nicht
dagegen wehren sollte deshalb denke ich
dass der konflikt mit china sich im
laufe der zeit noch verschärfen wird die
pest heimgesucht
aber es könnte ja sein dass china uns
zeigt dass das erfolgreichere politische
modelle gibt als die demokratie nämlich
einen staatskapitalismus
[Musik]
da bin ich nicht so sicher das
chinesische modell hat viele schwächen
so hat sich in den letzten zehn jahren
ein gewaltiger schuldenberg angehäuft
die chinesischen staatsverschuldung
gehört mit zu den höchsten der welt und
ist langfristig nicht nachhaltig
irgendwann wird dieser wachstumsmotor
ins stottern kommen
es ist allerdings nicht einfach
vorauszusehen wann das geschieht
ich erachte es als nicht gegeben dass
china ein erfolgreicher
wirtschaftsakteure bleiben wird auch
politisch gibt es probleme aufgrund der
fehlenden demokratischen legitimität der
politischen führung
es kann also durchaus sein dass china
zukünftig sowohl wirtschaftlich wie
politisch schwierigkeiten haben wird
wir sind schon fast am ende des
gesprächs mit ich würde noch
interessieren sie leben in stanford
mitten im silicon valley wo die großen
utopien der zukunft entwickelt werden
verschmelzung von mensch und maschine
unsterblichkeit
wie zuversichtlich sind sie dass es den
menschen in 100 200 jahren so wie wir
jetzt sind es noch geben wird
diese utopie im silicon valley hat sich
in den letzten paar jahren zum albtraum
entwickelt in den 90er jahren war man
gemeinhin überzeugt vom nutzen der
informationstechnologie und des
internets für die demokratie mit den
wahlen 2016 und der russischen um
nutzung des internets zur waffe der
chinesischen fähigkeit ihr internet zu
kontrollieren und ihre gesellschaft
abzuschalten ist klar geworden dass das
internet nicht notwendigerweise
demokratie freundlich ist
automatisierung und künstliche
intelligenz bedrohen viele jobs in
tieferen lohn segment was du populismus
und der steigenden wut gegen die eliten
führt diese trends werden weiter
fortschreiten
ich wage keine voraussagen weil wir
nicht wissen wie die technologie sich
entwickelt wir stehen aber vor einer
reihe von herausforderungen
ja das klingt gar nicht rosig und sich
schwierig da die hoffnung zu behalten
vielen herzlichen dank trotzdem für
dieses unglaublich interessante
gespräche francis fukuyama und um den
menschen der zukunft geht es auch
nächste woche
wolfram eilenberger spricht mit dem
paläogenetiker svante pääbo der das
neandertaler genom entziffert hat und
mit der politikerin fi war jena über die
chancen und gefahren von eingriffen in
unseren genen und jetzt gleich gibt's
musik ein berührender dokumentarfilm
über die südafrikanische sängerin miriam
makeba die vor zehn jahren verstorben
ist
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]